nouveau numéro de reporter le dock le
magazine de reportages long format de
france 24 dans le monde hyper connecté
où nous vivons difficile de ne pas
laisser de traces de nos navigations sur
internet et de notre passage sur les
réseaux sociaux dit affichons notre
quotidien nous y allons notre vie privée
nos relations nos centres d'intérêts nos
déplacements et bien plus encore et cela
sont toujours avoir en tête lusage qui
peut être fait de nos données ils sont
de plus en plus nombreux à prendre
conscience des dangers qui pèsent sur
notre liberté et notre indépendance
danger d'une exploitation commerciale
par les géants de l'internet danger
d'une surveillance étatique militants
pro-démocratie à hong kong adolescents
au maroc activistes en allemagne voici
un tour du monde de ceux qui cherchent à
passer sous les radars des algorithmes
disparaître c'est un document en
coproduction avec arte signé marc
meillassoux
[Musique]
non
cette chanson parle
de toutes vos photos personnelles que
vous postez sur internet
que vous même vos proches de tout ce que
vous êtes et rêvé d'être
[Musique]
lâcheté
mettant là
tous les jours nous laissons des traces
numériques
lors de notre navigation de nos échanges
en ligne ou de nos déplacements même les
données les plus inoffensives nos exposé
à de nombreux risques
n'oubliez pas que leur modèle économique
c'est de récolter le plus d'informations
possibles pour pouvoir ensuite les
vendre à ceux qui cherchent à vous
ciblez
on va pas avoir la même façon de se
protéger sita menace c'est parce que tu
as un mari jaloux une femme jalouse que
si c'est ton patron au travail que si
comme c'est arrivé pour moi je bosse
avec wikileaks sur des documents de la
nsa et de la cire
[Applaudissements]
c'est un sérieux avertissement pour le
reste du monde nos libertés sont en
train de s'évaporer enfin sous nos yeux
jeunes élèves citoyens ordinaires
journalistes dissidents nous avons tous
des niveau de menaces en ligne
spécifique mais les solutions existent
alors comment apprendre à nous protéger
chacun à notre échelle
j'entends dire que la vie privée c'est
fini mais je ne suis pas d'accord c'est
complètement faux il y a plein de façons
de se protéger
même dans notre monde sous surveillance
et hyper connectés
[Musique]
max tow metz est un acteur et musicien
qui vit à berlin grands utilisateurs des
réseaux sociaux et des services fournis
par les géants du numérique il a
récemment pris conscience du traçage de
ces données dans l'allemagne
d'aujourd'hui il sait que pour lui les
risques sont limités mais il s'inquiète
de la menace croissante que font peser
les gars femmes sur nos libertés
pour apprendre à protéger sa vie privée
il se rend au quai aux communes et que
j'aime comme tous les quatre ans cet
événement rassemble une communauté de
hackers et de passionnés du code venus
de toute l'europe pour partager et
construire un internet plus ouvert
[Musique]
mais content de te voir moi aussi j'ai
des questions à se poser
quand de mes grands objectifs
à la casse et de me débarrasser de
google
des
conseils pour google c'est de
compartimenter ses activités si tu
utilises une de leurs applications parce
que tu ne peux pas faire autrement tu
peux au moins essayer de pas utiliser
toutes leurs applications pour ne pas
leur dévoiler tout à fait
en général je conseille de diversifier
les outils qu'on utilise par exemple au
lieu de dépendre de google pour les
emails les cartes pour les recherches
les traductions il y a plein d'autres
outils qui respecte notre vie privée et
qui répondent à tous nos besoins je
conseille vivement de commencer par les
applications pour lesquelles vous ne
dépendez pas des autres par exemple
votre navigateur au lieu d'utiliser
google chrome vous pouvez utiliser
firefox vous pouvez utiliser chromium où
le navigateur tort il ya plein
d'alternative et une fois que vous avez
trouvé un nouveau navigateur pourquoi ne
pas essayer un nouveau moteur de
recherche 5 vous pouvez utiliser par
exemple dr qu est il y en a d'autres il
y a des gens qui utilisent cirque ce ou
pointe ya tellement de moteurs de
recherche respectueux de notre vie
privée
cet après midi on a eu une discussion à
propos de facebook tout le monde
voudrait s'en débarrasser mais personne
n'y arrive en fait woodside
oui donne en fait on sait pas vraiment
ce qui pourrait remplacer facebook et
notre société a du mal à comprendre à
quel droit et à quelle liberté elle
renonce en utilisant facebook
ma conviction c'est qu'on devrait avoir
le contrôle des algorithmes de ne donner
savoir exactement lesquels sont
collectées est ce qu'elle devienne et ce
n'est pas possible avec le modèle
économique actuel de ses angles tu as vu
à berlin l'opposition contre
l'installation de google dans le
quartier de kreuzberg quand on a entendu
parler ça a beaucoup attiré l'attention
sur l'emprise que google exerce sur nos
vies oui c'était incroyable même chez
google je pense qu'il n'a jamais imaginé
une telle opposition
en effet en 2018 google a dû renoncer à
un grand projet de campus à creuse berg
sous la pression de la rue
je pense que berlin est une ville assez
libre et les berlinois ont clairement
fait savoir lors de grandes
manifestations et en interpellant les
politiques que personne à kreuzberg ne
voulait d'un siège de google
comme la plupart des artistes max a
besoin des réseaux sociaux pour
promouvoir ses performances mais il y
six ans de moins en moins à l'aise
ce matin il a rendez vous avec des
membres du riesling leur coach ce
collectif rassemble des acteurs de la
vie nocturne berlinoise qui veulent
s'organiser de façon indépendante
il ya eu tellement de scandales sur
l'exploitation des données personnelles
et sur la surveillance des utilisateurs
notre idée c'est de lancer une grande
campagne où on inviterait les clubs et
toute la scène culturelle berlinoise à
choisir ensemble une alternative sur
laquelle ils pourraient poster leurs
événements
on a fait des recherches il ya un projet
en développement qui s'appelle
mobilisons et qui serait une alternative
à facebook evans
moi je suis surtout en contact avec des
artistes je suis sûr c'est une ville
comme berlin qui a une offre culturelle
unique ça serait un super point de
départ pour lancer l'initiative est
ensuite l'exporter dans d'autres villes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la protection de la vie privée nous
concerne tous désormais en première
ligne les adolescents grands
consommateurs des réseaux sociaux
instagram snap chatte et tik tok a
casablanca les enseignants du lycée
français louis massignon ont décidé de
montrer à leurs élèves la face cachée de
leurs applications préférées
aujourd'hui on va travailler autour des
réseaux sociaux déjà est ce que
quelqu'un parmi vous a déjà une les
conditions d'utilisation des réseaux
social à la moelle de conscientisation
franchement je n'ai jamais lu parce que
c'était mon très complexe et c'est
vraiment aux hommes n'étaient jamais
pris le temps de lire et je me dis aussi
si tout le monde et accepte je veux
c'est accepter
donc alors là c'est une avocate anglaise
qu'il a réécrit les conditions dans un
langage très accessible aux jeunes à
partir même donné mans alors bien que tu
restes le responsable des informations
que je passe sur instagram nous pouvons
garder utiliser et partager les
informations personnelles avec des
entreprises connectées à un instant
quand il ne sommes pas responsables de
ce que feront ces autres gens
en plus des données que vous allez
postez vous allez mettre ce qu'on
appelle des métadonnées l'heure à
laquelle tu étais connecté combien de
fois tu a leaké tel ou tel contenu etc
etc cet ensemble de données ils vont les
vendre à des entreprises qui elles mêmes
peuvent les revendre à d'autres
entreprises derrière
on va passer peut-être à au 2ème extrait
et après vas-y tu peux l'éviter
officiellement tué propriétaire des
photos et vidéos que tu postes mais nous
sommes autorisés à les utiliser ou pour
vous aussi des ces deux personnes les
utilisent et partout dans le monde
d'autre part nous payer pour
l'utilisation de celle ci mais nous
n'allons pas nous mais nous ont pas de
payer en échange
basset s'est vraiment fait penser c'est
comme si on fournissait on fournissait
le bois ou faisaient feu mais vous
n'avez pas la chaleur exact c'est ça et
en fait le cul mais par contre on
donnait la cheminée tu peux utiliser un
instagram gratuitement mais les données
elles sont à eux et ils les utilisent
c'est toujours comme ça
[Musique]
la vie privée des élèves est très
importante pour nous parce que si c'est
pas nous qui protège la vie privée de
nos élèves qui le fera les risques
qu'ils peuvent encourir sur
l'utilisation de leurs données sont
vraiment de trois types là
principalement l'exploitation des
données par les gars femmes ou les
entreprises qui sont en partenariat avec
ses grandes entreprises on a aussi le
risque que leurs données soient utilisés
par des hackers qui aurait récupéré un
contrôle sur leur compte ou sur leur
accès et après on a bien évidemment la
lignée de l'eau risques de l'utilisation
des données entre élèves pour réaliser
du cyberharcèlement outre
le cyber harcèlement sur les réseaux
sociaux est un fléau qui frappe de
nombreux jeunes pour essayer de prévenir
ce phénomène les enseignants apprennent
à leurs élèves à mieux protéger leur
compte
lors de la séance précédente nous
rappeler on a joué un peu à vous allez
chercher les failles sur le compte de
votre camarade votre habit est ce que je
peux avoir un peu mon retour par rapport
à ça déjà
sur son compte instagram est donc déjà
son tour à s'aggraver privé sauf que
c'est avec son prénom est dans sa bio ya
son âge et il ya sa photo de profil et à
sa tête et elle a pas de publication
sauf qu'il ya des story à l on voit les
voyages quand le voyage etc d'accord et
tu estimes que son compte comme ça va
chalach ya à faire peut mieux faire
je suis pas le meilleur exemple
et si vous prenez le temps de regarder
tous les paramètres de confidentialité
vous allez trouver de vrais trésors vous
pouvez par exemple décider qui peut voir
vos posts par défaut c'est peut-être
réglé sur public mais vous pouvez
décider de changer et ne laissait voir
vos posts qu'aux gens que vous avez
accepté sur votre page donc vous pouvez
décider quels utilisateurs ont accès à
vos informations
salah il est écrit autoriser les moteurs
de recherche à afficher votre profil oui
non et par des fossés wiki est cochée
donc c'est vraiment là que vous pouvez
paramétrer les options qui sont
importantes pour vous
[Musique]
un homme estimé à ce jour monsieur
meillassoux et je m'appelle wake et je
suis chercheur à hong kong enfin j'ai
suivi votre travail sur la sécurité en
ligne et j'aimerais vous parler de la
situation à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés face à la chine elle croise
le compte sur votre discrétion j'ai été
la plus prudente possible mais tout ceci
reste assez effrayant
comme des milliers de hongkongais wake
est pensée ne courir aucun risque en
ligne mais la révolution des parapluies
ce mouvement de résistance contre la
chine a tout changé
désormais les services chinois peuvent
surveiller les communications de tous
les citoyens de hong kong
alors dites moi comment ça se passe un
aliment la situation n'arrête pas de se
dégrader quelques mois la police est de
plus en plus violentes et il n'y a plus
de dialogue possible nous sommes tous
très inquiets
vous avez quelque chose en tête avec 5
la première chose que je voudrais faire
c'est apprendre à me protéger sur
internet nv et ensuite je pourrai aider
d'autres personnes
mon idée c'est de lancer une campagne de
sensibilisation pour le grand public
et je me demandais si vous pourriez me
présenter des gens qui pourraient me
conseillez house pictures
[Musique]
il cause ma expérience j'ai vécu en
chine et je connais bien les pratiques
du gouvernement chinois et
je sais que moi ils espionnent la
population comment il arrive à cibler
certaines personnes et j'ai peur qu'un
jour la même chose se passe en kung
fu chi pour que les gens puissent
continuer à travailler à défendre notre
état de droit et notre liberté
d'expression il faut vraiment qu'ils
apprennent à se protéger
[Musique]
allô allô bonjour ses ouailles quai
alors dites moi qu'est ce que vous
faites comme métier 1 je suis chercheuse
mais après l'insurrection je me suis
impliqué dans des formations de sécurité
en ligne et depuis j'organise des
campagnes d'information et de prévention
auprès des personnes à risque et vous
voulez en apprendre un peu plus sur ce
qu'on appelle le modèle de menaces ja
oui les modèles de menace c'est nouveau
pour moi
d'accord ça va vous permettre de
déterminer votre niveau de risque il y a
cinq questions à se poser
première question quelles données voulez
vous garder secrètes
le modèle de menaces c'est une démarche
qui vise à comprendre de qui je dois me
protéger quelles données je dois
protéger
quel serait le pire scénario auquel je
devrais faire face ça permet de réaliser
ok donc ce sont eux mes adversaires
voilà de quoi ses adversaires sont ils
capables est ce qu'ils peuvent
intercepter mais communication
obtenir des données auprès de mon
fournisseur d'accès internet sont-ils en
capacité de pirate et mes données
des éleveurs suisse dames face des
adversaires sont des services de
renseignement savaient ils ont des
ressources financières et techniques
importantes chaque du camp power
je crois que mon plus grand risque ce
serait de mettre mes contacts en danger
c'est ce qui m'inquiète le plus
le pire scénario pour moi serait d'être
arrêté je serai alors interrogé et dans
le pire des cas torture et aux toitures
testing ces choses sont monnaie courante
en chine emeline china
[Musique]
la surveillance sur internet est devenu
un problème majeur pour les journalistes
en les contactant leur source risque de
laisser des traces en ligne qui pourrait
ensuite servir à les identifier et les
poursuivre
pour répondre à cette problématique
julian assange a co fondé en 2006
wikileaks
cette plateforme sécurisée permet aux
lanceurs d'alert de transmettre des
documents sensibles en préservant leur
anonymat
wikileaks a notamment fait connaître au
grand public les exactions commises par
l'armée américaine en irak et en
afghanistan
peut-être que c'est celui d'armes il ya
les fenêtres sur les côtés c'est un
fourgon pénitentiaire
mais je ne sais pas s'il vient par ici
ça pourrait être lui
devenu l'homme à abattre du gouvernement
américain je les nas anges et depuis
2011 sous la menace d'une extradition
aux états unis où il risque désormais
175 ans de crise
[Applaudissements]
la première prise de contact avec une
source c'est devenu un vrai problème
pour nous les journalistes
imaginons par exemple que vous êtes un
lanceur d'alerté et que vous avez des
informations importantes à me
communiquer si vous m'écrivez depuis
disons une adresse gmail à votre nom que
vous utilisez depuis des années ou si
vous m'appelez depuis votre téléphone
cet échange va laisser une trace
numérique permanente entre vous et moi
et
moi je propose différents niveaux de
sécurité donc quelqu'un qui ne risque
rien à me contacter une contact sur
twitter sur facebook par mail voilà y'a
pas de quelqu'un qui potentiellement
pourrait éventuellement être ennuyé si
jamais on savait qu'ils m'avaient
contacté contacté par signal est
quelqu'un qui a un très haut niveau deux
modèles de menaces typiquement à
quelqu'un qui bossaient ou kibo serait
pour un service de renseignement qui a
bossé pour un service de renseignement
qui voudraient me confier un document il
peut passer par sigur d'europe qu'un
logiciel qui est précisément ont été mis
en place pour permettre de contacter de
façon anonyme et sécurisée un
journaliste d'investigation
[Musique]
des
fûts en 2010 j'étais le reporter du
spiegel à londres avec ceux du new york
times et du gag dans une sorte de
bouquet rogalle y est on a ensemble
rédiger les premiers rapports sur la
guerre en afghanistan
et quand on les relit aujourd'hui c'est
très étonnant tout ce qu'on pouvait
écrire à l'époque dans le simple mais
et wikileaks nous envoyer sans cesse des
demandes très énervante et répétitif
pour qu'on chiffre tout et qu'on soit
toujours plus prudent viviane et nous
font rigoler entre nous de ces gros
parano
mais on travaillait ensemble c'était une
vraie collaboration ave journalistique
et aujourd'hui je me pose la question
que j'ai fait des sites différents par
rapport à julian assange
j'irai même plus loin si on lit bien la
demande d'extradition des états unis qui
sont les prochains sur la liste je veux
dire qu'est ce que nous avons fait
concrètement de différent
[Applaudissements]
si on est en possession de documents qui
peuvent être compromettant et qui sont
des documents d'intérêt public mais
qu'on sait pas trop comment s'y prendre
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut en premier
lieu c'est identifier le bon
interlocuteur s'est identifié le
journaliste qui sera capable de rendre
public un document en minimisant au
maximum le risque
est ce que je conseille en général c'est
d'acheter un nouvel ordinateur portable
bon marché une petite tablette ou
quelque chose comme ça
d'aller dans un café où il ya un réseau
wifi public de télécharger le navigateur
tort est de se connecter à la page
secure drop
vous pourrez ainsi rentrer en contact
avec nous en nous envoyant un message et
nous pourrons ensuite passer à l'étape
suivante et voir quelle serait la
meilleure manière de récupérer vos
informations sans compromettre votre
sécurité
[Musique]
de son côté max explorent la piste
mobilisons cette alternative à facebook
events qui doit bientôt voir le jour
aujourd'hui avec d'autres artistes il a
rendez vous avec les développeurs de
mobilisons pour discuter du
fonctionnement de la plateforme
alors nous en tant qu'artiste qu'est ce
qui fait qu'on est encore tous sur
facebook
oui depuis 15 ans nous avons pris
l'habitude de tout confier et de tout
déléguer à facebook l'hébergement des
données la maintenance des serveurs
alors que si vous voulez créer une
instance de mobilisons il faut que
voulait bergier quelque part et que vous
payez l'hébergement du serveur et ses
ouailles freedom mais c'est ça le prix
de la liberté ce sont les coups que
facebook et les autres nous cachent ils
récupèrent en nous volant notre vie
privée
ça au hockey donc si j'ai bien compris
que ça veut dire qu'on peut avoir notre
propre serveur local ce que tu appelles
une instance a
ensuite on installe le logiciel dessus
là il donne un nom mobilise berline
insight et on pourrait inviter les
artistes les clubs de berlin à venir sur
notre plate forme est là vous pourrez
communiquer avec les utilisateurs des
autres serveurs en allemagne et dans le
monde entier c'est bien ça il ya
exactement c'est le modèle fédérer c'est
un nouveau paradigme
[Musique]
la plateforme fédérer la plus connue est
le réseau social mastodonte
depuis sa création en 2016 plusieurs
millions d'utilisateurs ont choisi de
migrer de twitter vers cette alternative
libre
le mot fédération signifie qu'il n'ya
pas une autorité unique qui contrôlent
la totalité du réseau mais des autorités
multiples si vous êtes un habitué des
emails le système des emails aussi est
un réseau fédérer il y a les serveurs
tels que hotmail outlook yahoo et gmail
vous vous inscrivez et on vous donne une
adresse mail qui commence par votre nom
d'utilisateur et se termine par le
serveur que vous avez choisi et ce
système vous permet d'envoyer un e-mail
à n'importe qui sur n'importe quel
serveur à partir de votre adresse
donc la fédération est un système qui
permet de répartir des autorités
contrairement par exemple à twitter ou
facebook où il y a disons un serveur et
des millions d'utilisateurs
sur vaste aux dons comme s'est
décentralisé il y à un grand nombre de
petits serveurs
chaque serveur appartient à quelqu'un ou
à une organisation qui le gère et vous
permet d'interagir avec n'importe qui
sur n'importe quel autre serveur
pour préparer le lancement de la
plateforme mobilisons max a invité ses
amis artistes à une crypte au parti
lors de cette soirée informelle les
néophytes peuvent découvrir des
alternatives aux gars femmes et
apprendre les bases de la sécurité en
ligne
nous allons parler de navigation est ce
que vous savez ce que c'est qu'un vpn
oui pardon un vpn réseau privé virtuel
non non
beaucoup de gens protègent leur vie
privée en se connectant un vpn pour
ensuite accéder à internet
l'avantagé que votre adresse ip à l'air
de venir du vpn et pas de votre propre
réseau et cela protège en partie votre
identité
vous avez déjà entendu parler de tort
oui et vous savez la différence avec un
vpn pas vraiment non non non ok
c'est l'acronyme de 10 onion août le
routeur en union européenne en date
c'est un peu comme un vpn dans le sens
où votre connexion à internet semble
venir d'un autre endroit
bat mais avec thor et vous n'avez pas
une seule protection nous en avait trois
parce que vous passez par trois adresses
ip différente avant de vous connecter à
l'internet et avec toutes les couches
successives d'où l'appellation du auteur
anglais votre connexion à internet est
théoriquement anonyme bien sûr elle
n'est plus si vous vous connectez
ensuite à facebook
e
la table d'à côté se concentre sur la d
googlisation des téléphones android
il existe en effet des alternatives pour
la plupart des applications
par exemple google maps peut être
remplacée par openstreetmap ou cointe
maps pour ne pas partager sa
géolocalisation avec google
je comprends pas bien comme g1 android
lié à mon compte google mon téléphone
tout entier et connectés à google donc
ils ont de toute façon accès à mes
deniers
en effet n'en voyez aucune donnée à
google nécessite une opération plus
complexe il faut remplacer entièrement
le système d'exploitation android par un
système d'exploitation comme linux libre
et open source
généralement le mouvement crypto parti
préconise le logiciel libre et open
source vous connaissez pardon libre et
open source pour d'ivry open source
libre et open source en gros ça
appartient à nous tous
le code source est disponible et tout le
monde peut le prendre c'est mieux
l'utiliser le modifier de partager avec
d'autres personnes on ne peut pas faire
plus transparent
[Musique]
en français j'explique le logiciel libre
avec ces trois mots liberté égalité
fraternité
parce que c'est exactement l'idée du
logiciel libre
liberté signifie que chaque utilisateur
est libre d'utiliser le programme
égalité parce que chaque utilisateur a
les mêmes droits et fraternité parce que
les utilisateurs sont encouragés à
coopérer entre eux
mêmes des pratiques malveillantes les
plus répandues ces l'espionnage des
utilisateurs
vous devez partir du principe que tout
programme non libres envoie des données
sur vous et votre activité en ligne à
des entreprises est peut-être un état
[Musique]
pendant que 3 2
ces dernières années le monde de
l'éducation a entamé une grande
transition numérique à casablanca le
lycée français louis massignon s'est
lancé dans l'aventuré dès 2017
l'équipe enseignante a dû faire un choix
entre différentes solutions notamment
celles proposées par les gars femmes
avec en toile de fond la question de la
collecte des données des élèves
on a testé cinq ou six solutions au sein
de l'établissement il y avait plusieurs
solutions donc des solutions payantes de
l'open source et du coup on a bien vu
qu'on ne pourra rien contre de chaque
solution les géants du numérique nous
ont proposé les vis ta ble ment des
solutions immédiates pratique consiste à
intégrer onomique sympathique agréable
cependant ce qui guide notre action et
celle de tous les enseignants c'est la
liberté pédagogique or ce que proposait
ces géants du numérique c'était une
solution clé en main est une solution
clé en main en général elle est
restrictive
en termes de respect de la vie privée et
des données qui sont collectés on était
en adéquation avec le logiciel libre et
du coup on a toujours eu tendance à
vouloir privilégier les solutions open
source plutôt que des solutions
propriétaires one autre qui est une
solution de microsoft étaient aussi
proposées dans ce cadre là mais en fait
il s'est avéré que ce n'est pas adapté
au contexte scolaire paul goury
classroom on s'est vite rendu compte
qu'on devait utiliser la messagerie
le drive de google pour assurer son
cours il impose le fait d'avoir
d'affecter une adresse e-mail à d'élèves
chose qui n'est pas pas
quand on veut mulot pour les collégiens
et les élèves du primaire et du coup les
enseignants l'ont rejeté
[Musique]
l'équipe a finalement choisi la
plateforme moodle et le logiciel big
blue bottone une alternative à zoom mais
ce choix n'a pas tout de suite fait
l'unanimité en effet le logiciel libre a
la réputation d'être moins facile à
prendre en main
[Musique]
mundel ont embrassé un peu rebutant ne
l'est pas c'est pas très sexy c'est pas
très intuitif c'est très abrupte a peur
des parts d' approche et puis parce
qu'en fait justement ça permet aux profs
d'être hyper créatif on peut tous faire
absolument tout ce qu'on veut il est
modulable à l'infini
[Musique]
et comment
à londres s'ouvre le procès en
extradition de julian assange
dans la prison de haute sécurité de
belmarsh ces cinq semaines d'audience à
l'abri des caméras sont présidées par la
juge vanessa bas writer
les etats unis demandent l'extradition
de monsieur assange pour la publication
illégale de documents confidentiels sur
les guerres en afghanistan et en irak
cette publication aurait pu mettre en
danger la vie d'informateurs travaillant
pour les états unis
la poursuite d'un journaliste pour
publication de documents confidentiels
est une première historique
en occident la profession s'inquiète du
précédent juridique que cela pourrait
créer
les comptines l'x comment ça se passe ça
se passe que déjà on signe un engagement
de confidentialité
comme quoi je vais respecter l'embargo
j'ai respecté les protocoles de sécurité
on communique par des messagerie
sécurisée et ensuite on a accès de façon
sécurisée également aux documents et
idéalement on va utiliser tales taille
c'est un système d'exploitation amovible
ça tient sur une clé usb une carte sd on
redémarre son ordinateur sur tales et là
toutes les communications passent par
thor
c'est un ordinateur qui n'est pas relié
à mon identité
donc ça me permet d'avoir un niveau
d'anonymat supplémentaire
quand notre modèle de menaces est très
élevée on essaie généralement de
travailler de manière déconnecté ça
signifie qu'on utilise des ordinateurs
qui n'ont jamais été et ne seront jamais
connecté à internet et on va ouvrir
certains documents chiffrés uniquement
sur ces machines déconnecté dans les
bureaux de dender sceptre new york ils
ont même construit un local sécurisé et
isoler une sorte d'alcatraz avec des
plaques de métal dans les murs pour
bloquer tout signal venant de
l'extérieur
depuis 2020 une nouvelle loi chinoise
vise directement les opposants au
congrès
face à cette menace oui qu'est anime
désormais des workshop pour les
activistes sur les règles de sécurité en
ligne
wafa alors merci d'être venus
aujourd'hui nous allons parler un peu de
sécurité mais avant de commencer je
voudrais parler de la loi sur la
sécurité nationale
qui d'entre vous a entendu parler de
cette nouvelle loi
en pratique dès que le gouvernement ne
t'aime pas quelle qu'en soit la raison
ils peuvent envoyer en chine pour être
jugé par un tribunal chinois et c'en est
fini pour toi
une heure du coup nous devons nous aussi
renforcé nos mesures de sécurité ce qui
est vraiment important c'est de chiffrer
vos communications et notamment vos
mails mr
choi
il s'agit aussi de vos camarades si vous
êtes pris vos amis sont pris aussi j'en
ai parlé avec d'autres activistes que je
connais et ils ne savent même pas ce que
chiffré veux dire c'est terrifiant
si j'envoie un message sur internet
depuis cet ordinateur je peux l'envoyer
sans le chiffrer et n'importe qui en
chemin ou wifi mon routeur ou aux
fournisseurs d'accès ou qui que ce soit
d'autre
tous ces intermédiaires peuvent
potentiellement le lire alors que si je
le chiffre avec pgp plus personne ne
peut lire facilement
donc on utilise deux clés tous nos deux
numéros un premier qui va simplement
brouiller le message que je veux envoyer
comme quand je croise ce papier
pour bien comprendre
donc quand je l'envoie les
intermédiaires ne peuvent que le
transmettent
[Rires]
les comptes il reçoit tu as ta clé
secrète l'autre numéro pour le
déchiffrer c'est comme un ouvre-boîte
cette voie là et c'est ça que nous
devons apprendre à revel
je
je m'en fous
dans la société civile les gens ont
souvent des connaissances techniques et
limité et ils ont en face d'eux des
adversaires qui ont d'énormes moyens
pour rentrer dans les appareils et
intercepter les communications
et dans ce cas là il faut se détacher de
la stricte sécurité informatique est
plutôt réfléchir en termes de sécurité
opérationnelle la sécurité
opérationnelle ça consiste avant tout à
changer son comportement pour minimiser
les risques cette démarche est souvent
bien plus utile que d'acheter du
matériel considéré comme plus sécurisé
[Musique]
lors de sa création
internet était la promesse d'un nouvel
espace de liberté mais aujourd'hui il
est surtout contrôlé par des grandes
entreprises et des états
pour préserver notre vie privée nous
sommes obligés d'apprendre à nous
protéger par nous mêmes
de prendre ma star le problème c'est
qu'aucune force politique majeure n'a
réussi à proposer une vision de ce à
quoi internet pourrait ressembler s'il
n'était pas entré les mains
d'entreprises assez peu imaginatives et
qui ne pensent qu'à vendre de la
publicité
la manière dont on a organisé l'ensemble
du système est une pure folie nous
n'avons pas été capables d'imaginer des
structures qui pourraient avoir une
politique économique différente où les
données pourraient être détenus par les
citoyens et non par les entreprises qui
nous offre l'infrastructure et c'est ce
genre de question qui à mon avis devrait
faire partie du débat le débat
c'est désormais vers bruxelles que se
portent les regards en effet l'union
européenne est l'institution qui a
montré la plus grande volonté de
remettre de l'ordre dans le far west des
données personnelles
en unissant nos forces au niveau
européen avec les états membres nous
pouvons vraiment mettre en place un
nouveau standard global le règlement
général sur la protection des données
qui encadrent le traçage des
utilisateurs notamment par les coûts qui
a déjà marqué un tournant historique au
niveau international mais en dernier
recours je pense que nous devrons des
manques les les grandes entreprises
avant d'en arriver là bien sûr il ya
d'autres solutions
développer la concurrence et pousser les
entreprises à faire de la protection des
données la force de leur modèle
économique
[Musique]
on
pourrait imaginer d'autres services qui
serait financé et développé en
respectant la vie privée avec un modèle
économique différent il y en a qui
émergent déjà dans le cadre
d'initiatives locales le problème c'est
qu'il faudrait une dynamique derrière
tout ça il m ait les moyens investir des
milliards d'euros dans ses services et
pour être capable d'injecter des
milliards d'euros il faut d'autres
priorités politiques aux niveaux
national et européen
c'est le jour j pour max et ses
partenaires après deux ans de
préparation ils lancent leurs
plateformes indépendantes mobile à
espère line
désormais connectés à des milliers
d'autres plateformes elle apporte une
nouvelle pierre à l'édifice de
l'internet libre
aujourd'hui on est là pour fêter
mobilisons et lancer le site web c'est
pour ça qu'on vous y invite là c'est
l'adresse de la plateforme elle est en
ligne il ya des fonctionnalités super
cool elle est connectée aux faits divers
ce qu'est l'avenir des réseaux sociaux
open source libre et décentralisé
voilà inscrivez vous
[Applaudissements]
au fond d'où vient notre liberté si nous
sommes libres aujourd'hui c'est
uniquement parce que dans le passé
certaines personnes ont accepté de faire
de vrais sacrifices pour leur liberté
nous n'avons pas besoin que des milliers
ou des millions de personnes deviennent
des héros et prennent des risques
énormes
nous avons juste besoin que des milliers
peut-être des millions de personnes
acceptent de subir quelques petits
désagréments
la seule chose qui compte c'est notre
capacité à dire non si de temps en temps
vous dit non vous ne ferez pas ça car ça
signifierait renoncer à une partie de ma
liberté vous ferez avancer la lutte pour
reconquérir notre liberté dans l'espace
du numérique
[Applaudissements]
flo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car
voilà pour ce document co production
avec arte signé marc meillassoux et vous
pouvez évidemment le retrouver sur
internet et sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est la fin de ce magazine merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter sur forza
[Musique]